ein dorf auf dem mond das hört sich erst
mal total verrückt an und nach rubia
wirklich großer zukunftsmusik aber das
soll bald schon realität werden sehr
genau daran arbeitet gerade die
europäische raumfahrtagentur kurz esa
mit hochdruck arbeitet sie daran ja und
wie der aktuelle stand bei diesem
projekt ist dabei möchte ich jetzt mit
jan wörner sprechen der chef der esa
guten abend herr werner ja ein dorf auf
dem mond das hört sich ja wirklich in
unseren augen als laie erst mal verrückt
an vielleicht könnt uns da so ein
bisschen einblick geben was da der
aktuelle stand und wie soll das aussehen
also daran ist ein journalist schuld
also ein kollege von ihnen gab vor ein
paar jahren ein begriff in die runde
geworfen der hieß multipartner open
konzept klingt sehr kompliziert sollte
heißen wir gehen mit mehreren partnern
zum mond und bleiben dort auch und haben
aber ein offenes system nicht so wie in
der vergangenheit wie im wettbewerb vor
50 jahren um in dem rennen zum mond
sondern offen
und dann hat der journalist zu mir
gesagt das ist kein guter begriff wählen
sie einen besseren begriff und daraus
ist moni village oder mond dorf geworden
also was gemeint ist ist dass wir
sammeln weltweit und das läuft bereits
das ist sehr erfolgreich akteure die auf
dem mond etwas machen wollen und da gibt
es viele da gibt es firmen die dort zum
beispiel ressourcen sich anschauen
wollen wasserstoff und sauerstoff aus
wasser gewinnen
andere wollen aber vom mond aus von der
rückseite tiefer ins universums schauen
es gibt viele interessante und das ist
eigentlich genau das was ein dorf
ausmacht dass verschiedene akteure
zusammen kommen aber gibt es dieses dort
denn jetzt aktuell schon beziehungsweise
wann wird dass das dann geben und immer
gefragt ist wann ist denn die
grundsteinlegung für diesen für dieses
montag das ist im prinzip sage ich ja es
gibt es schon denn diese idee die
dahinter steht das verschiedene akteure
zusammen kommt das ist genau das was
jetzt passiert wir die europäer wir
bauen zum beispiel mit den amerikanern
gemeinsam eine schwerlast rakete die
astronauten zum mond bringen kann wir
bauen mit den amerikanern auch eine
station die um den mond herumfliegen
wird wir bauen mit dem russen zusammen
ein landa der auf dem mond fliegt also
es gibt ganz viele projekte und deshalb
gibt es nicht zu den typischen anfall
wie anfang des montags wie bei einem
projekt sondern viele projekte zusammen
gründen das mond dorf und deshalb sage
ich dass montag gibt es schon
er war schon einige e-mails bekommen
dass leute sich beworben haben und
wollen gerne bürgermeister sein
das musste ich dann auch erst erklären
und was sagen sie was macht diese
faszination von dem mond aus aber es
gibt eine wissenschaftliche faszination
der mond ist wahrscheinlich entstanden
durch den aufprall von einem anderen
himmelskörper mit der erde deshalb ist
es ein museum ein archiv der erde
das ist die wissenschaftliche seite es
gibt die technologische seite auf dem
mond dinge auszuprobieren zum beispiel
auch wenn man später vielleicht mal zum
mars fliegen will und dann gibt es auch
die ganz menschliche seite wir alle
kennen den mond wir sehen den mond oft
in den nächten anders wird können auf
den mars sehen aber wir kennen nichts
auf dem mars mit bloßem auge glaube der
mond ist so etwas wie wirklich für den
einzelnen bürger die bürgerin erkennbare
ort zu dem man vielleicht fliegen könnte
danke schön herr hörner für ihre
spannenden einblicken ein schöner abend
vielen dank für sie mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schau dich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren